[Music]
do you want to sell your car but don't
want to leave your home
you don't have to this month shift
launched its service in las vegas
providing an
alternative to the traditional method of
selling a car
it starts with you receiving an online
quote for your car on shift.com
you can then book an evaluation
appointment where someone comes to you
evaluates your car and makes a final
offer
if you accept you complete the
transaction digitally right then and
there
including digital payment and dmv
processing
toby russell says during the pandemic
this convenient and safe way to sell
one's car
really saw an uptick favorable
and positive reaction to the idea of i'm
not going to like take my car
and go place to place the place and
interact with a lot of people and have
them getting in and out of my car and
doing all that
i certainly don't want to like put my
car on you know craigslist and have like
random people coming to my house
and so what people have really liked is
the ability to like literally push a
button
have somebody come pick up the car you
get the price right there online
and he says the entire process takes
about an hour we did ask him what the
pricing is based upon and he said it's a
computer algorithm that decides what's
fair based on tens of thousands of other
cars like yours